louisiana senator john kennedy we showed
the wide shot of new orleans a short
time ago
senator welcome uh i tell you it's kind
of disturbing but it's all too familiar
our flight team our drone team was able
to capture people just
running full sprint one of which on one
two guys in handcuffs
across our border why is there not a
why can can't there be a bipartisan
sense of outrage
everywhere in seeing this
well the uh the department of homeland
security
has announced that the uh the border is
closed
but they lie like they breathe i mean i
don't mean to be
ugly but they lie like they breathe when
i heard when i heard the secretary say
the border is closed
uh my mind went back to that image of
president clinton looking the american
people in the eye and saying
i did not have sex with that woman we
know how that turned out
uh i've been to the border if you if you
believe the border is closed you believe
in the tooth fairy the easter bunny
and the jimmy hoffa died of natural
causes we'll have two million
people come into the united states this
year illegally
thanks to the body administration they
have no idea
who they are except they're coming from
all over the world
the bite administration has almost
completely halted
any kind of deportation of people
already here legally
america has been has become one giant
sanctuary city and the shame of all this
is that in addition to uh violating the
law and being
dangerous it undermines legal
immigration
right most americans support legal
immigration i do
we we welcome a million people to come
into our country you'll never get reform
while that's happy to have them you'll
never get reform as long as this is
happening ever
canada's seal the northern border sealed
the southern border it's chaos romanians
are coming through
well president biden has put around him
um i know he's a nice guy he is a nice
guy i've talked to him but the people
he's put around him
are extremely radical
i mean they live in crazy town they need
an exorcist
these folks really believe that vetting
people at the border
is racist they think that unlike any
other country
in the history of the world we are
supposed to just
welcome anybody who wants to come in
crazy without asking any questions and
that
that just american people don't support
that
and president biden knows it so that's
why i say so many of his people lie like
they breathe
you mentioned the dhs secretary
alejandro mayorkas talking about the
border being closed we put together a
montage
of him saying that over and over listen
to this
we are elevating our messaging
so that the individuals do know that
they
cannot come to the border the border is
closed precisely that the border is
closed
the message is quite clear do not come
the border
is closed the border is secure the
border is secure
the border is closed we've been
unequivocal
in that the border is not secure you can
look at all of this video we play it
almost
every single day of more groups coming
through what's your reaction
well i i know the secretary look here's
what
dc is is all about the thing that most
people in washington d.c
want is to keep their jobs and i'm sure
the secretary
wants to keep his job and i'm sure he's
been told by the biden white house
to uh to just say okay the prop the
borders closed and so many people around
president biden believe that the
american people are morons
and that they'll just believe whatever
they see on television and they're not
morons and they don't believe it
because it's not true and i think they
know that
but but this just shows you the contempt
that so many people in the body
administration have
for the for the american people and that
is why
we are showing those images from our
drone team
the administration may say it's closed
but clearly it is wide open
senator uh i know on capitol hill uh the
number one priority right now
seems to be to try to get for the
republicans a
an infrastructure bill uh your
suggestion is about a third of their
latest
there seems to however have been a
little compromise because the
president came back he lopped about a
half a trillion dollars off of it
and this is what one of his senior
advisors said about the infrastructure
along with bernie sanders and where it
could go next
look he wants a deal he wants it soon
but is there meaningful negotiations
going
taking place in a bipartisan manner he's
willing to
let that play out but again uh he will
not let inaction be the answer and
when it gets to the point where it looks
like that is inevitable
inevitable you'll see him uh change
course
we would like bipartisanship but i don't
think we have a seriousness on the part
of the republican
leadership to address the major crises
facing this country you know if they're
not coming forward
we've got to go forward alone so in
other words bernie sanders wants to blow
up the system do it by
reconciliation however as we heard from
the first advisor
joe biden is willing to change course if
the republicans don't deal
their offer is still three times more
than what you guys are willing to do
so he's going to have to change course
isn't he
well as soon as president biden puts an
infrastructure bill in front of me
i will consider it but right now his
infrastructure bill
he's basically asking me to buy a car to
get the cup holders
only about five maybe 10 percent of his
infrastructure bill is infrastructure
and the rest of it is the green new deal
a federal takeover of child care
and reparations now if the president
wants an
infrastructure bill we can put one
together with our democratic friends in
the senate very quickly
it'll be six to eight hundred million
dollars it'll be roads bridges
ports sewer water broadband
we can tell him how to pay for it by
repurposing some of the coronavirus
money
and by scrubbing the federal budget a
little bit but he
he doesn't want to do that and i don't
think the white house is
really interested in infrastructure bill
they're more interested in
in a federal takeover of child care so
they can control the
curriculum and a green new deal and
reparations and that's why we haven't
been able to come together
we all know logic tells you but if i see
if i see a real infrastructure bill i
and most of my
uh my republican colleagues will pounce
on it like a ninja we just hadn't seen
one yeah i mean you're at 600 billion
you'll go up a little i'm sure
but not when you're gonna we're going to
have to pay for eldercare
school lunches as well as preschool and
you've got to militarize the irs
to go raid and find some way to get more
money out of the most successful people
in this country
and continue that vilification process
my sense is
with inflation with every single thing
that we buy and use
now doubling in price from gas to lumber
the american people are not going to be
okay with this maybe they might
maybe they might have been okay with it
three months ago but not now don't you
think that there's
a sense out there that things are
getting out of control with the spending
well the the biden white house is
spending money like a sailor on
shore leave in fact there's a bill
uh senator schumer has a bill in front
of the
senate right now that's gonna cost
probably 250 billion
dollars and he says we need it it's
backed by the
white house to fight communism and make
us more competitive
and it's probably going to pass because
some of my republican colleagues
have swapped brains with the democrats
and they're going to vote
for it uh they want to give 50 60
billion dollars to big
tech now we all know big tech is broke
they want to give 60 billion dollars up
to 3b in the company
to big tech so they can make a better
algorithms to more quickly
censor us i mean it makes no sense like
they did with china like they agreed to
do with china
yeah so in biden he ran on that student
loan forgiveness but it's not in his uh
latest his upcoming budget
he told the new york times the idea you
go to a to pen for 70 000 a year
and the public should pay for that i
don't agree but he ran
on that what is what message does this
tell the 42 million americans that were
gonna get ten thousand dollars
lobbed off of their student loans many
of them went to the polls to vote for
him and he's not fulfilling that promise
well i think i think the white house is
being realistic
uh they don't they don't have the votes
to pass it number one
and number two the american people don't
support it
um i don't understand why all loans
don't matter
you know what why student debt why not
credit card debt why not car loans and
that's not and what the president
was asked he was asking the american
people
many of whom didn't go to college to to
pay for those who did go and what about
the people
who've already paid off their student
loans um
here's what our policy on student debt
ought to be
number one you borrow the money number
two pay it back
problem solve right it's that easy all
right senator always a pleasure to send
spend a little of our monday mornings
with you thank you for joining us today
from louisiana
thanks guys thank you